okay [ __ ] okay [ __ ] I'm it's a boy
it's a little boy psycho [ __ ] bad
ball okay and we're back at it we're
back at it it's just loaded so I got a
little time to educate y'all people I
got a new chair I you know I got a
second displays reckon if you check of
[ __ ] recorded it's kind of nice and way
we're playing the last of us and we are
gonna do the level museum okay okay Oh
loading that's good that's good that's
what we want yes Oh God got a little
more for dad a little more for daddy
they're their daddies there I got a kit
what the [ __ ] oh ok shut ok last thing
that happened is we got up oh [ __ ] going
on we got it better there we're going
this way ok I have a [ __ ] [ __ ]
spider-sense oh shut
I get anything I could [ __ ] him through
here uh-oh she says she came down the
ground like a [ __ ] spider I got a guy
in here yes yes oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] they
don't even [ __ ] notice how how many
not notice like a they just like too
busy crying I got [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there's a
lot of [ __ ] on the ground Can I grab
from the front no I can't oh sure
there's like bars and shut up now there
that daddy's hair you can go to sleep
now oh yeah gotta sleep now look she's
or guys and what's that noise [ __ ] try
not to [ __ ] hit anything okay here we
go here we go i'm a sleepy time I real
that's what I said okay oh sure
okay okay a [ __ ] oh just like that daddy
knows how to deliver okay batches okay
guys are just [ __ ] me that like
pretending that I'll notice that I just
did this fine climb on up spiders hands
not sure oh he's crawling he probably
has like quads [ __ ] steel hey thank
God cat [ __ ] yeah my ass up we're coming
I know oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] close there's
no way they got me us with
oh man I got so much precum coming out
of me my dick is my rock solid sorry oh
that's so unsanitary I hate when I do
that can I keep that yeah sorry how do
we get out of this place that's a good
[ __ ] kosta [ __ ] some Arlene thinks
you're up sick what now here we go Oh
finally yeah only good I'd sneak out I
was nervous military boarding school I
need to upload this clip capacité baybay
that place is completely off limits how
the hell are you getting there I had my
ways anyways oh sure what you guys call
runners bit me ah [ __ ] i don't know i
don't know what the [ __ ] to do yeah
horizon this I think that Lily just
[ __ ] gives me one I went to her I go
on I guess hope she's alright I told me
what says peace again can i upgrade now
no I need maximum health ooh weapons
break rapping speed and he had held our
listen mode yeah
okay how do I get out of here no I guess
they're looking around for an exit but I
found a door that's okay I used to it
again used to doing everything in this
[ __ ] game just a little help will be
nice a little help I could oh I love
mommy good god Johnny likes cha-ching no
[ __ ] is it lit do I have to [ __ ]
throw it all right listen nothing yeah
what's that [ __ ] happen here yeah oh let
me check it to you the other one's still
good I know like [ __ ] shirts was good
but you got that dress anything get in
here anything for daddy dad any of the
new pair wails oh hello Jessica ok I can
I get you
anything around here that I could take
Thanks [ __ ] oh this is gonna be it hi
Jake this how the [ __ ] don't trust this
place an old museum some of these things
are hundreds of years old what's in here
I'll take that thank ya house like this
town I hear something your septum tired
a all right what you hear I'm alive huh
I'll make my way around yes ah this is
just sucking guy get all clicking what
the [ __ ] what I
Tess you can't see me that right come on
[ __ ] I thought I can't grab those
these legs almost be hard like I'll take
that brick thank you very much we my
sister go that way [ __ ] I can't [ __ ]
tell check this place out real quick oh
you want a burger it don't you Tess yet
anything in here could be quiet the [ __ ]
is that a safe oh yeah I'll take day say
thank you [ __ ] anything behind the store
no there isn't anything needs a chef Cat
Cat Cat Cat I oh [ __ ] can I closed doors
behind me no I can't that [ __ ] sucks
tough [ __ ] is that noise hey you're like
fighting all right i'll take my time
yeah [ __ ] spores everywhere okay it
says it's clear behind here [ __ ] like I
sit save the bullets kill this bet
killer gotta sleep got a sick child
gonna sleep got a slight yeah good it's
gone on back there bakken [ __ ] Dex fine
I girl [ __ ] ah there's pie some good
[ __ ] in here they always do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] go down here just like
scoundrels I think like [ __ ] zombies
right Oh [ __ ] shutter
five mustard and flows and I'd horrible
that thank you get a [ __ ] reloaded
that was I did Terrell James's all right
guys what what you know like outside and
let me heal i guess and use this gun cuz
i can hold them all right now i have
different ammo types creeped out hmm
there's definitely some secret [ __ ] over
there huh a lot why twice okay it's just
to show me that i can't go that way
that's great yeah it's just just great
yeah Jase hmm this is very like New Age
half life you gotta find a way oh that's
a firefly thank oh [ __ ] there she is
that's all doing it but in the capital I
get it take this one feel like this
could [ __ ] here but the games like not
letting me go see you buddy the games
like a very forceful okay it's too so
it's one gonna break or something what's
going on oh I'm glad I'm very glad this
is like relaxing for you but ok daddy
doesn't like to do all right I walked
your step as you go now because it's
gonna be a little but it's just [ __ ]
found either be insane Oh dusty I saying
ok that's a that's so gonna end us down
here i guess i'm not a cut to say that
everything you hope for ya ok this is
gary still out man you know Jan tonight
I've you yes yes and these views for
youto for money this way thanks so much
hey yeah hey pick it up
we're almost done stay focused yes ma'am
ditch out for Harambee